(pensive music)
- [Narrator] Moscow said it captured
the Eastern Ukrainian town of Soledar,
which would be its first
major gain since July.
(gun firing)
Kiev says the fighting
around the town continues
but Russian state media
is already celebrating.
(reporter 1 speaking in foreign language)
(reporter 2 speaking in foreign language)
The reports have amplified
the strategic importance
of this small town
as Russia's recent advances there
offer President Vladimir Putin
a rare opportunity to celebrate.
- It's allowed him to claim a victory
after a series of very humiliating losses.
(gun firing)
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] But the reality on the ground
is more complicated than
propaganda reports suggests,
highlighting the questions
about what's next in the war.
Soledar, a town with a pre-war population
of 10,000 people has been the focal point
of Russia's offensive and
media coverage in recent weeks.
It is just a few miles north
of the larger city of Bakhmut,
which Russia has unsuccessfully tried
to seize for months now.
Russian media has described both Soledar
and Bakhmut as critical for Ukraine.
(reporter 3 speaking in foreign language)
But Western officials and
military analysts are skeptical
about Soledar's importance.
- Get what's been
happening over the last 10
and a half months,
particularly in the Donbas.
Towns and villages have
swapped hands quite frequently.
- [Narrator] And beyond Soledar,
even if Bakhmut fails,
defense experts say the cost
of six months of fighting
in the area far outweighs
any operational advantage for Moscow.
- It has been the most
brutal theater in the war
over the last six months, and
Western intelligence estimates
that each side in the conflict has now had
about 100,000 casualties.
- [Narrator] Recent
satellite images also show
numerous bomb craters
from artillery all over Bakhmut,
suggesting Russia has spent high volumes
of ammunition in the offensive.
The price Russia pays for the
contested territory is missing
from the state media coverage
while reports highlight the heavy losses
suffered by Ukraine.
(reporter 4 speaking in foreign language)
- We don't have exact
estimates for Ukrainian losses
but Ukrainian officials
have repeatedly said
that the fighting is is very difficult
and there have been heavy
losses on both sides.
- [Narrator] Now, even
if the state propaganda
is enthusiastic about the
prospects of Russia's campaign,
(reporter 5 speaking in foreign language)
Ukraine says the celebration is premature
as fighting continues.
(bombs exploding)
- The big question is
if Ukraine can regroup
and establish a second line
of defense and stop Russian
advances where they are
or if Russians will
continue to break through,
and if it's the first scenario,
then this will not be
a very significant loss
for Ukrainians.
And if it's the second, it
could have a larger impact.
(pensive music)